birds are living dinosaurs and that
shift is one of the most spectacular
transitions in the history of life this
year researchers studying both fossils
and modern birds figured out how one
group of dinosaurs became smaller more
adaptable the change happened pretty
quickly setting the stage for the avian
explosion the arrival of modern birds
think Frankenstein meets the Fountain of
Youth
researchers stitched two mice together
one young one old and connected their
circulatory systems the connection
rejuvenated the brain and the muscle of
the older Mouse it appears young blood
contains a factor that can turn back the
clock on the aging process this year
several teams showed that robots like
people can accomplish more by working
together in one study a thousand robots
each the size of an American Quarter
joined together like a marching band to
form squares and letters and shapes
another team inspired by termites
designed a robot swarm that built
three-dimensional structures researchers
who make computer chips are breaking
from their old ways in 2014 they created
the first large-scale neuromorphic chips
these chips are designed to process
information in ways that are more like a
living brain the chips could make it
easier for machines to carry out
perceptual tasks such as vision and more
capable robots could also deal with a
lot of data from sophisticated
environmental sensors scientists who
work with stem cells have reached a
long-sought goal they turned human stem
cells into pancreatic beta cells that
can secrete insulin the important cells
are missing and people who have type 1
diabetes
but doctors can't yet transplant the new
cells into patients that's because the
cells would be rejected as foreign still
the achievement brings a possible
treatment for diabetes one step closer
when it comes to ancient cave art
researchers have long believed that
Europe held the world's oldest examples
but this year researchers announced that
a cave in Indonesia holds hand prints
and paintings that they believe are
thirty five thousand years old the fine
suggests that modern humans were pretty
creative by the time they left Africa
and began settling the rest of the world
in 2013 brain scientists made a cool but
kind of creepy discovery they could
instill a fake memory of fear in mice to
do it they manipulated neurons with
light and this year they took the method
one step further they used a similar
technique to switch good memories to
fearful ones and bad memories to more
pleasant recollections in 2014
researchers launched a record number of
cube SATs into space a CubeSat is a
pint-sized low-cost satellite but
they're starting to do some real science
they're cheap and easy to launch and
they can carry very powerful sensors
that means in time constellations of
cube SATs may do the job that now takes
a single complex and pricey mission the
DNA code usually includes just four
letters G C a and T but this year
researchers added a new pair of letters
X and Y and they managed to insert these
extra letters into living bacteria next
up they want to use the extra DNA
letters to code for amino acids that are
not normally part of the proteins that
organisms make and now the breakthrough
of the year that is the sound of a comet
it was recorded by the rosetta
spacecraft in August after a 10-year
journey
Rosetta became the first probe to
orbit a comet then in November it made
history again dropping a small Lander
that drifted to the comet's surface but
the landing was awkward it bounced and
ended up in a place where it couldn't
recharge its solar panels still it
collected a lot of data before its
batteries ran out now Rosetta is chasing
the comet it's going to watch its jets
of gas and dust turn on as the comet
nears the Sun the results could tell
scientists a lot about how our solar
system formed and what brought water to
earth